Tucker's back baby Tucker on Twitter
available to stream now
I lost count of how many views it has
Tucker on Twitter has got like a
bazillion views
a hugely successful launch
the the episode is about 10 to 11
minutes and I thought well wait he's not
doing his whole 30 minute show or I
guess it was an hour long show on Fox
but then I remembered that when it's on
cable news half of that is commercials
so you're actually not losing too much
Tucker content it was it was an
excellent first episode and
he went even further
than he would on cable it was a similar
kind of show but he went even further
because now he's not constrained by the
rules of one of these big establishment
news corporations
the Russians are dying it's the best
money we've ever spent Graham says a
smile spreads across his thin quivering
lips as he forms the words he looks like
a starving man contemplating a breakfast
buffet the aroma of death has aroused
Lindsey Graham thanks so much replies
zelenski he feels the same way see
there's nothing dark here just two
middle-aged guys celebrating the killing
of a population they don't seem like the
kind of people who'd enjoy flooding
Villages or starting a famine in any
case who cares if they are it's really
not your business your job is to support
Ukraine the media lie they do
but mostly they just ignore the stories
that matter
what's happened to the hundreds of
billions of U.S dollars we've sent to
Ukraine no clue
who organized those BLM riots three
years ago no one's gotten to the bottom
of that what exactly happened on 9 11
well it's still classified how did
Jeffrey Epstein make all that money how
did he die how about JFK and so
endlessly on
not only are the media not interested in
any of this they are actively hostile to
anybody who is in journalism curiosity
is the gravest crime
great stuff one Tucker's writers and
Tucker himself is a right he's a very
talented writer himself they're just
phenomenal that that bit about Lindsey
Graham's quivering lip as he thought
about the war in Ukraine is so mean so
vivid so really good stuff and then
Tucker is beginning to answer one of the
big questions about the future of his
show which is
does Tucker work without the constraints
of cable news part of what made the
Tucker show so great was that he was
saying it on cable news cable news which
had been so milk toast and reigned in
and a lot of these hosts even the
conservative ones just kind of towed the
uniparty liberal line and Tucker comes
out and he contradicts it
a lot of people on Fox News even but
throughout the cable news they wouldn't
invite really conservative people on the
air
oh no the real conservatives they're
going to be blacklisted and then Tucker
comes on he says yeah no forget about
that we're going to have all these guys
on I'm gonna have whoever I want on the
show
well the question was does that work
when you take away the constraints and
the answer I think is yes Tucker is
doing the same kind of show but going
further
talking about
aliens talking about foreign policy
talking about 9 11 raising questions
about 9 11. raising questions about the
JFK assassination and saying I'm going
to go further I'm going to push further
than I previously could before it's just
a way forward if this works Tucker leans
in and adapts himself to the medium
which he obviously is doing
this could be a real death blow for the
establishment long-standing Legacy Media
we're now premiering movies on Twitter
that get a bazillion views like we did
with what is a woman last week we're now
premiering presidential campaigns on
Twitter not the smoothest rollout ever
but impressive that it happened
RFK Junior now Democrat presidential
candidate using Twitter to advance his
campaign for a town hall
now now Tucker Carlson biggest
Cable News host ever
coming to Twitter
getting bazillions and bazillions of
views if this succeeds every sign says
that it has the media landscape
has fundamentally changed and changed
for the better people are raving about
genucel skin care Jessica from
Huntsville Alabama says my skin looks so
soft and clear I've seen a reduced
number of fine lines and dark spots I
found a new lifetime product absolutely
love it Jen you sell skin care uses a
one-of-a-kind proprietary flower base
developed by the founder and pharmacist
who is a great guy by the way it's also
comes along with rare Botanical extracts
and Powerful antioxidants for skin care
results that work guaranteed I said I
would not endorse the product if I could
not try it if I were not impressed by
the product and also fellas I know
sometimes men are a little skeptical of
getting into Cosmetics too much even
slightly more men than women use
genuscal and for good reason genucel's
most popular package is available to you
today for seventy percent off 7-0 at
genucel.com knowlesyt join millions of
happy customers who've already fallen in
love with the results Plus for a limited
time get genu cells probiotic extract
moisturizer free with every most popular
package go to genucel.com knowlesyt
genucel.com
knowlesyt now speaking of the media
something very very telling about this
whole point with the way movies are
being released now presidential
campaigns being released Tucker
Carlson's new show there's a UC Davis
study app
the UC Davis study
asks can movie reviews predict box
office success and you would think from
that question the question is if the
critics like a movie does that mean that
the movie is going to do well
necessarily and if the critics pan a
movie does that mean the movie is really
dead
no it doesn't
actually the opposite is true so what
what the survey found was that positive
reviews
signal that a film will flop
and negative reviews signal that a film
will be a hit
this published by UC Davis just just a
few days ago
what does this tell you this tells you
about a lot more than just movies this
tells you
one we are living increasingly in a
totalitarian state
not just an authoritarian state where
the governors the rulers have a little
bit of a heavy hand a totalitarian state
where the ideology of the state seeps
heavy-handedly into everything into art
into all forms of Education into all
sorts of public rituals into the
language we're allowed to use into the
thoughts that we're allowed to have
that's totalitarian it's when it's a
total state
it would be a distinction here you could
see between
communist Soviet Union and Francisco
Franco's Spain
Francisco Franco was an authoritarian
ruler but he basically tolerated
diversity he tolerated people doing
pretty much what they wanted to do but
they couldn't insist upon it in public
they couldn't make a big show about it
they couldn't
go out there and March against his
regime he would suppress that kind of
stuff but he didn't send the thought
police into your home to tell you that
you got to use certain pronouns okay he
actually had a looser hand than that
whereas the Soviet Union would encourage
people to rat on their neighbors rat on
their family the Communist totalitarian
States really insist upon the ideology
at every single level all of the time
that's more of the society we're living
in now
because the ideology of the state is not
just coming from the congressmen or the
politicians it's coming from the movie
reviewers it's coming from the
mainstream media broadcasters it's
coming from the teachers it's coming
from the sports it's coming from ESPN
it's just everywhere okay but the people
know that it's BS the people oppose it
and so
when the people see that the
establishment likes something they
assume it's bad and they won't go see it
when the establishment sees when the
people see that the establishment hates
something the people will go see it they
will like it
you see it on Rotten Tomatoes the way
you know a movie is going to be really
really good is when it has a very low
critic score and then it will have a
high audience score and now because
Rotten Tomatoes has has messed around
even with how the audience score works
now even the audience score isn't
totally reliable so that's that's one
thing that it tells you that's the most
important thing that that study tells
you the second thing that this study
tells you is that movies are a dead
industry
they're effectively a dead industry at
this point
the studios are churning at all the same
crap the Oscars don't reward movies that
people like the Oscars only reward
movies about like 15 year old gay
cowboys or whatever that nobody's gonna
go see
and the critics are in on it the critics
are part of the film industry the
studios are part of it the Distributors
are part of it the actors are part of it
the writers are part of it and it's just
kind of dead
and it's been it's been dying for a long
time and so if movies or just premium
content generally meaning miniseries
extended series
Middle Ground kind of shows if that's
going to have a future it's not going to
have a future in Hollywood
the future of that is going to be
outside of Hollywood maybe places like
Tennessee or maybe elsewhere boy what a
great clip that was make sure that you
ring the bell like the page subscribe to
the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
we'll see you next time